CAMDEN OLSON: Danny, ready?
Buddy.
[MAKES KISSING SOUNDS]
Sit.
My career path is that I want
to work with service dogs,
to be able to communicate
with an animal
and to teach that animal
to literally save someone's
life on a regular basis.
When I work with a dog, I just --
I feel like I have a purpose.
My name is Camden Olson.
I'm Class of 2019.
I'm majoring in ecology
and evolutionary biology
with a certificate
in cognitive science.
I knew I loved dogs
and that I wanted
to train service dogs from
a pretty young age, since I
was 7.
Ever since then, I've been
trying to train guide dogs
and service dogs.
I've just fell in love
with it more and more.
I decided to take
a gap year and so
I took a year off between
high school and college
to raise a guide dog.
I just -- I hadn't quite had
the time yet and the experience
to fully devote to
training and what
I wanted to do in terms
of training service dogs,
and so my gap year
was my opportunity
to be able to do that.
SUBJECT 1: That is
how gentle they are.
CAMDEN OLSON: I am really
interested in animal behavior.
For my thesis, I want to train
a diabetic alert dog and then
so answer research
questions on that,
and then take the dog
into a middle school
and have the dog work with
middle school students
who have trouble
paying attention
and see if there are any
effects on student performance
and behavior in the classroom.
CHRISTINA RIEHL:
Could you identify
a list of candidate
schools that might
be the ones that you approach?
CAMDEN OLSON: OK.
CHRISTINA RIEHL: You
know what I mean?
Like say --
CAMDEN OLSON: I
have two professors
that I've been working with,
both in the EEB department.
And one of them in
particular, Professor Riehl,
she is amazing.
She's so enthusiastic
and supportive.
And I've been talking to her
about what I want to study
and what kind of
research I want to do,
-- details about the experiment.
What I love is the training
as much as I love the dogs,
and you work together with
a dog to succeed as a team.
I am just so
passionate about it.
It's -- the effect that
the dogs have on people,
the feeling that I
get when training.
And just all of it is
just so incredible to me
that it's really hard
to put into words.
Ready --
But it really leaves
me speechless how
I feel when I work with a dog.
Good job.
Good boy, yeah.
Ready?
Danny out.
Yes, good job.
Yeah.
Good boy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]